hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren sandra ist mittlerweile so faul
geworden dass sie nicht mehr mehr zu mir
kommen für Videoaufnahmen jetzt bei ihr
aufnehmen ja das ist ähm Vulva warum
nicht zu machen
die Wette gilt was Facebook geh auf
interpol.com
[Musik]
zum Besuch auch ein Big Mac Menü
mitnehmen
sprechen sie auch Deutsch ja wir
sprechen auch deutsch witzig wo kommen
Sie denn oder oder ihr wo kommt ihr denn
her haben die bei ihnen die Handtücher
gewechselt heute das haben die bei uns
vergessen aus Remscheid ja wir sind aus
Köln ne und das Frühstück war da für
euch was dabei ich fand das war jetzt
nicht so besonders ne fünf Sterne ja
bisschen wenig Käse ist ihr Zimmer auch
so was hast
[Musik]
du mich besuchen kommen
ich weiß nicht wie das riecht aber stell
dir vor du bist so auftragen ne und du
bist einfach noch
[Musik]
fremdgegangen
2 Jahren
eine Kopfschmerztablette reinhaut dann
lest ihr euch auch nicht den
Backpfeife
wenn ich zu Hause sitze
ich mag Frauen die geschminkt
[Musik]
genauso geil aussehen wie Geschmäcker
Damen gleich
dämlich Fragezeichen
oder was ist deine Aussage so
Leute hier wohnt einfach Dieter Bohlen
[Musik]
um lachst du denn nicht ich bin Game
durchgespielt bin zu sein
[Musik]
ich würde mal sagen so ein Nasenpiercing
okay warum weil keine Ahnung
Alter
ich habe ja gar kein Auto und wie komme
ich zur Arbeit oh ich bin arbeitslos
okay falscher Alarm
ich sehe so ein Fensterscheibe ist so
ein Zettel dran
steht auf einmal Name Chiara Müller
Alter mit so einer Telefonnummer ich
dachte mir so alter stabil scheuer
geklärt ohne dass ich was gemacht habe
die hat direkt Nummer aufgeschrieben was
mein Auto diese Entschuldigung für den
Schaden einfach meine Schnauze
angefangen
so hallo da bin ich wieder ich habe
heute wieder meine Sachen mitgebracht
genau ich bin jetzt hier in meinem
Übungsraum da hast du mich schon drauf
markiert ich habe nie Videos von mir
selber gedreht hast du damals schon so
Videos
[Musik]
in der Stadt Leute guck mal hier ist ein
30er Schild und wenn man auf die andere
Seite geht dann hört die 30er Zone auf
das heißt das ist nur dieses kleine
Stück hier
[Musik]
die Folge geht noch 15 Minuten
abgeschalten
er ist eine neun von zehn aber er hat
keinen Führerschein
[Musik]
manche Leute haben nur Angst vor Gott
hallo
Gesamtvermögen wird aus 1,3 Millionen
Euro geschätzt stimmt das
wie wurden das erschätzt ist ja lustig
es ist wirklich größer als das Dings
[Musik]
wer soll noch
also
eine Frage habe ich ein paar Kranke
ausgesucht drei Stück von so einem viral
gehenden
Sprichwort es ist noch kein Meister vom
Himmel gefallen
mal angenommen ein Bäckermeister macht
ein Fallschirmsprung bleibt er dann oben
wenn es ein Tandemsprung war bei ihnen
beide oben
wenn ja wie kriegt man die dann wieder
runter
halt dein Maul bist bereit für Witz
Nummer 2 nein
ja was mache ich damit den Wurm
Frage von dem Kegler 56 kennt ihr
eigentlich das sprechwort geld stinkt
nicht
stimmt
haben sicher zu gehen dass er nicht
schlecht wird und doch zum stinken
anfängt am besten immer sofort ausgeben
richtig weil es wieder Blick aussieht
wieder wo wir Profilbilder
[Musik]
also wäre Leute
Sonne ja ist richtig sehr gut
Zucker sind so lecker ignoriert mein
Furz
[Musik]
und an der Stelle meine Damen und würden
wir euch nicht lachen heute heutige
nicht lachen Challenge auch beenden wenn
es euch gefallen einen Daumen hoch oder
dem Video hier da abonniert meinen Kanal
und klickt auf die Glocke verpassen ich
kann gehen ey du spinnst doch gar keinen
Fall